hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well what is the
function of pleasure in ethics and in
the Good Wife Aristotle addresses this
in nikka mccann ethics book 10 by
framing pleasure in terms of activities
and this is going to have a lot of
important implications some of which
we'll talk about in other videos one of
the things that he starts with in
discussing this is pointing out that
pleasure itself is not what he calls a
emotion akin ASIS a process of change
why because it is as he says perfect and
the word perfect there could mean its
fullest it's it's fulfilled it's the
word comes from the the term that means
and the Telos it in Greek so a pleasure
has its fullness you might say at each
moment that it's being experienced now
this doesn't mean that pleasure doesn't
admit of degrees but when you have a
particular degree of a pleasure do you
have that fullness of pleasure it is
genuinely pleasantest part of what
Aristotle is trying to get get towards
having us understand where as emotion is
something incomplete at every moment he
uses the example of walking right so I'm
walking here I'm walking there there are
certain points along the way the walking
is not complete at any given point
unless we say that the completion
consistent having walked in which case
the walking no longer exists we can go
on and on and further into depth with
this but I want to get through the rest
of this he also says that because
pleasure is not itself a movement and is
perfect at each moment that it exists
it's not simply a result of a motion or
even the process of becoming a process
of coming into being so what is pleasure
then he member actually comes out and
tells us precisely what it is here in
this discussion of Nicomachean ethics
but it does correlate it with another
important concept and that is an area in
Greek which we translate by the term
generally activity or action sometimes
function so a pleasure is going to be
connected with activity pleasure arises
out of activity it's not something
purely passive the way that we often
imagined it to be
instead it's going to arise sort of as a
you could think of it here temporarily
as a by-product or as something
additional but it's really going to be
intrinsically connected with activities
so Aristotle starts out by considering
the senses right sights hearing smell
taste touch all these other aspects
touch that we lump under the sense of
touch and Aristotle said is each sense
each each faculty right the capacity for
seeing ants in relation to its its
object it does something it has a
activity or a function what's the object
for you know visible things well a
little the chalkboard the video that
you're watching right now that camera
right there it really only has two
senses you know it has a sense of sight
you're seeing me right now and it has a
sense of hearing because there's a
microphone in the camera tics
you know those awful little arthropods
that we get stuck on to us apparently
they only have two senses they can sense
heat and they can sense motion or
vibration rather and that's what tells
them to drop down into something and to
stick stick there and a little proboscis
into us and start sucking the blood each
of those senses has a determinate range
of object so if you think about what
human beings can see you know just watch
some YouTube videos and you're gonna see
some amazing stuff right and that's
seeing something that a camera is
mediated now we're going to outside and
like just look around here you want
panoramic vision just just spit it out
you've got your your panoramic vision of
things of course you can't take it all
in at once but you know we can go on and
on and on
think about whether your nose can
differentiate now think about what it
dog's nose can differentiate think about
what your your palate can differentiate
human palate it's pretty well-developed
thinking about all the things that go
with touch you know hardness smoothness
we can go go on and on and out about
this right every one of those has to do
with what Aristotle's talking about here
each sense acts in relation to its
object not just the thing that's being
seen right now but the seeable the whole
range of what can be seen he says that
it acts perfectly and again remember
we're perfect does not mean you know the
sense of perfect that we often have
today but it works to its fulfillment it
works to its full capacity
it works towards its goal its end when
that sense is in good condition so you
know for example right now the camera
that you're looking at me through
through it is a blur because I need
these glasses right there's something
wrong with my sense of sight which has
to do primarily with those eyeballs that
I'm using to to mediate you know they're
kind of out of shape the lenses aren't
quite the way they're supposed to be so
I have to supplement it with this
prosthesis of glasses that now I put on
and now everything's very clear although
not quite the same color
unfortunately because these have a
little bit of tint to them so that's one
example you know when when you're sick
things don't taste the same way to you
because your body probably needs
different things right or it's out of
the condition when yours
your sciences are all clogged up you
can't smell much of anything which also
affects your sense of taste and might
affect your sense of hearing if your
tubes get blocked up so when our senses
are in good condition then they act
perfectly we can take in what it is that
they're driving us with and then they
produce a certain determinate pleasure
this doesn't mean that they don't
produce any pleasure when they're not
working to full capacity but the the
amount of pleasure that they can produce
is dependent on what they're able to do
so you know for example if you have
damaged hearing like like I do too many
you know
concerts and wearing headphones to fool
companion turned up all the way whether
you're not supposed to and also not
wearing like earplugs when I was in the
Army there are some things that I cannot
hear as well that other people can which
means that I won't be able to take the
same amount of pleasure in them because
my sense of hearing is not working as
perfectly they're the remedy for this of
course is I just you don't turn it up a
little bit right but then that could
produce a lack of pleasure for other
people who want to turn down a bit in
any case the general idea is that each
sense when it's acting in the way that
it's supposed to pleasure results from
them and there are some notes that each
one of the senses and it's not just the
senses it's also other capacities of us
he has examples here of thought da going
on the you know the intellect of the
rational part of us or contemplation
when we are literally being spectators
when we are contemplating something
there is a pleasure that goes along with
that as well so you know when you're
good at doing mathematics and you think
about a particular proof that's been you
know elegantly worked out there's a
certain pleasure to that that is
distinct from the pleasures of the
senses that are also genuine pleasures
now Aristotle says that pleasure
perfects the activity again the sense of
perfecting means to bring up to its
fulfillment to make it fully what it is
to be to fully actualize that we might
say in the contemporary language so
pleasure perfects an activity when we're
seeing and we derive pleasure from what
we're seeing that is making the activity
fuller it is making it better
Aristotle says that there's other ways
in which the activity is also perfected
and pleasure is not doing that so it
doesn't perfect it as a axis or a state
or habit does right so when we're
thinking for example about contemplation
pleasure does not perfect the activity
in the way that the intellectual virtues
do and it doesn't perfect it in the way
that the object does how does the object
perfect the activity the object actually
offers itself and is something that can
be seen something that can be touched
something that can be smelled something
that can be thought something that can
be contemplated it also doesn't perfect
it in the way that the faculty does the
faculty engages itself in the activity
in the entire game so all of these are
working together and pleasure is one of
the key elements or key components were
dimensions if you like of the activity
strip away pleasure from the activity
and it would no longer be totally what
it is this is a very interesting idea
the implication is that we're feeling a
low grade of pleasure probably all the
time that we're seeing hearing and that
is directing us in a certain way we can
also feel much more pleasure and then
the activity itself it's sort of like
the icing on the cake it doesn't make
the cake but it sure makes the cake
better in many respects it makes it
taste better of course so there's a
little self referentiality here right
gives a better
feel as as we often say now one of the
things that aerosol says to sort of
close this discussion oh that's very
interesting is that we are not capable
we human beings that's not to say all
beings feeling the same pleasures
indefinitely and why not he says there
we go
how is it that no one can feel pleasure
continuously so he suggests perhaps it's
due to fatigue no more human faculty is
capable of uninterrupted activity
therefore pleasure also is not
continuous because it accompanies the
activity of the faculties we can't
always be seeing even if you pry our
eyeballs open sooner or later we fall
asleep right although that's pretty hard
to fall asleep when your eyeballs are
pried open you're on you also lose focus
after a while you know that's why have
you ever seen the movie that Clockwork
Orange do they've got that guy in the
chair and they've got his eyes splits it
open they're having to drop eyedroppers
in just to try to keep them working with
that smell is a great example something
that stinks or something that smells
great about two minutes later you really
can't smell it much at all unless it's
very very strong because our order
receptors are not that powerful taste
works in much the same way hearing you
know you could hear something
continuously but after a while you'll
stop paying attention to it just like
when you put on music and you're really
attending to it and then you lose your
train of thoughts and then you don't
realize that you've listened to the
entire CD same thing with with
intellectual activities reading never
past your eyes over a page and read
through the lines and then realize
you've gotten to the end of the page and
don't remember anything that you've read
because we weren't paying attention
that's the faculty sort of disengaging
itself so he says it's for the simple
reason some things please us when new
but it seems to get
pleasure later this is because at first
the mind is stimulated and acts
vigorously in regard to the object he
has in the case of sight when we look at
something intently but afterwards the
activity is less vigorous and our
attention relaxes and consequently the
pleasure also fades so the degree in
which we're able able to have a pleasure
depends in part on what's going on with
these faculties and the activity that
those faculties make possible for us
this is a very different look at
pleasure than seeing pleasure is merely
sort of stimulus response a kind of
passivity you know this is a very
actively oriented conception of pleasure